I don't think we ever have to do
something like crazy fancy or something
extraordinary to have a fun time and
just you know have good mother-daughter
bonding well it seems that still true
today says Lori Loughlin daughters
Olivia Jade and Bella have returned to
social media to wish their mom a happy
55th birthday Bella was at first posting
this shot writing quote happy birthday
mama I love you Olivia Jade posted this
throwback shots a day later quote one
day late happy birthday I love you so
much it's the first time either as
posted since news of the alleged college
scam broke earlier this year Lori and
her husband are accused of paying five
hundred thousand dollars in bribes to
get their daughters admitted to USC they
have since pleaded not guilty on all
charges they do want them to have
somewhat of a normal you know finish out
high school college experience the
situation reportedly caused tension
between Lori and her daughter's though a
source told ET their relationship has
improved a second source told et time is
helping to heal I mean I'm glad to see
them out in the world on having a good
time but just to be with them just to
hang out with them now is so much fun
because they have they're funny they
have adult near their sense of humor is
very adult-like now Olivia and Bella
aren't the only ones wishy Laurie a
happy birthday though Laurie's when
calls the heart co-star Erin craco
posted this shot writing quote happy
birthday to my forever friend with a
heart of gold
love you et was with Erin this weekend
where she exclusively broke her silence
on Hallmark cutting ties with Laurie
what was that absence like on set if you
can even speak about that I don't know
if you can
I miss her very much yeah she's my best
best friend so that's that was hard not
adding her there obviously we know that
we know you guys were so close and I do
feel like you've handled it so well
thank you I appreciate it yeah we were
we were happy to see that the fans
continued to support the show and rally
around us and and we've really felt that
love so thank you
[Music]